en su día fue considerada la mujer más
odiada de reino unido que nunca se
casaría con carlos y mucho menos se
convertiría en reina camila sant es el
nombre de pila de camila parker bowles
hija de un comandante del ejército y de
una aristócrata su selecto círculo
social la llevó a conocer a el príncipe
carlos en un partido de polo a
principios de los años 70 la joven
pareja se separó cuando carlos se alistó
en la marina y camila se casó con el
oficial de caballería andrew parker
bowles con quien tuvo dos hijos mientras
tanto carlos se casó con la joven diana
spencer con la que también tuvo dos
hijos pero carlos y camila reavivaron su
relación y en 1993 se publicaron en la
prensa conversaciones que revelaban el
alcance de su amorío camila no era
querida especialmente si se le comparaba
con diana que era adorada por el público
británico tras la trágica muerte de
diana en 1997 los asistentes de la
realeza se dedicaron a reconstruir la
imagen de la familia incluida camila
ella y carlos hicieron una primera
aparición pública
dos años después en 2005 pudieron
casarse pero siguió para poder materna
por supuesto
que más en los años posteriores la
dureza de la prensa mengua en gran
medida aunque una parte del pueblo sigue
siendo implacable camila ha sido
firmemente aceptada dentro de la familia
real ha dicho que está cerca del
príncipe harry y de william y que no es
en absoluto la madrastra malvada en
febrero de este año en el aniversario
número 70 en la subida del trono de la
reina isabel finalmente camila obtuvo la
bendición de convertirse en reina
consorte su sincero deseo